we all have around 20 000 genes encoded
in our genome
some of these genes are important for
metabolism others for transporting
oxygen around our bodies and others that
control our hair growth
but are there any genes for longevity
well to cut a very interesting story
short no there are no such things as
longevity genes
but the story does not end there
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i've
prepared an interesting tale of
exploration into this question from
understanding why there is no such thing
as longevity genes to discussing the
heritability of longevity
and why it's rather possible that you
will have genetic variants that will
have some impact over your longevity
and finally we'll look at how much of
aging is genetic
so an obvious beginning is with good old
muscle organisms whereby genetic changes
cause great perturbations in their
lifespan
pioneering work in this field comes from
cynthia kenyon who discovered genetic
mutations and worms that dramatically
extended their lifespan
specific mutations in these worms
enabled them to live up to 10 times
longer
and conserved mutations of these worm
genes in other model organisms also
extended their lifespan with extensions
of up to 50 in mice and flies
now there are two interesting points
about these studies
the first is well what are these genes
doing and secondly a conversation about
monogenic versus polygenic traits
so firstly the genetic mutations
what genes are they in and what do those
genes do
well the mutation discovered in the
kenyan lab back in 1993 that doubled the
lifespan of worms was in a gene known as
daf2
now daft2 encodes a protein that is a
regulator of the insulin igf2 response
so for example signaling following high
sugar levels
typically the signaling pathway promotes
growth
however the presence of this mutation
reduce signaling through this pathway
and instead of growth the current
consensus is that there is a switch to
more protective mechanisms such as
expression of antioxidant genes or
stress response genes
and other genetic mutations and
different components of those pathways
or similar pathways such as mtor and
ampk
have also been shown to influence
lifespan in muscle organisms
now collectively these different
proteins and their signaling pathways
are referred to as the longevity
signaling pathways
but that doesn't mean they are genes for
longevity
the genes have really important
functions within cells
it's just that their aberrant activity
of these factors seem to be influencing
the aging process and therefore
perturbing it seems to have some
longevity benefits
but it would be incorrect to call the
gene a longevity gene
but importantly these different
signaling pathways are conserved from
yeast through to us humans which is why
lifespan extension was also seen in the
flies and mice not just the worms
now you might be thinking if these
mutations are conserved from worms to
mice then what about humans
well i would say what a great question
and remember that second point i said
we'd come back to a conversation about
monogenic versus polygenic traits well
now we're coming back to it
so the studies i discussed above refer
to lifespan extensions after just a
single mutation
and when a trait comes from just one
mutation such as the case of lifespan
here it is often referred to as
monogenic
now more commonly this is referred to in
the context of disease for example
sickle cell anemia is due to a single
mutation hence it's a monogenic disease
and so the opposite is the case with
polygenic conditions then in polygenic
cases multiple genetic variations are
involved within a trait
so what about aging
well similarly to the model organisms
studies above monogenic changes have
been seen in human patients that can
strongly promote health or reduce
longevity
for example patients with laryn syndrome
have a mutation in the growth hormone
receptor which is all part of the same
pathways we saw earlier and this
mutation reduced signaling so whilst
their growth suffers as a result of this
mutation patients with laryn syndrome
have short stature but due to their
reduced signaling they also show a
reduced risk of age-associated diseases
such as type 2 diabetes and cancer
conversely other monogenic mutations in
humans advance aging for example in
progeria patients
despite these cases of a single mutation
having quite a strong phenotype
longevity or lifespan is a complex trait
that is affected by multiple factors
now quite often i talk about the
non-genetic factors such as diet
physical activity health habits and
psychosocial factors
as they can be interesting to think
about in terms of translational
implementation into our own lives but
there is still a genetic component
but this genetic component does not just
refer to one gene out of the 20 000
genes we have on our genomes
and they're not necessarily even
restricted to regions of genes but
that's a story for another day
but the point is that we all have
different genetic variations that affect
how our bodies function and therefore
could be implicating our own longevity
an interesting observation that has been
seen so far in genetic studies of aging
and humans is that at least at
increasingly older ages so living beyond
100 years the genetic component becomes
exceedingly strong so that ratio of
non-genetic to genetic factors seems to
be stronger in centenarians
but which genetic variations in humans
have been linked with lifespan
well one way to examine this is through
so-called june and wide association
studies i explain this in another video
but simply here it's a way of comparing
the genetics of people with a very
similar if not the same characteristic
to people without the traits and to see
whether there is a correlation between
the presence or absence of this trait
and genetic variations
so in the case of lifespan the phenotype
is lifespan and then they look at what
genetic variations are associated with
having a longer lifespan
the catchers this isn't quite as simple
as i've just described as the results
have been a bit underwhelming
which may be correct that the genetic
component of aging is underwhelming
compared to the non-genetic influences
but anyway some interesting results have
come from these studies
in fact more than 50 different genetic
loci have been identified
however only a few of these have been
repeatedly seen in multiple studies
one of these is in the gene apoe which
encodes a protein that has been linked
with alzheimer's disease and another is
in the gene folso3 interestingly
the one equivalent of foxo3 has been
associated with longevity in the
organism
now these different genetic variations
have a small effect size when it comes
to genetics of lifespan in other words
the smaller section of variation that
contributes to genetics in whole
accounting for heritability well just
part of that can be explained by these
variants there is also misinheritability
for human longevity
so what could this be and why should we
care
well firstly it's cool
but more seriously identifying variants
or genes associated with longevity
if you then find out what those genes do
it may help to understand the biological
underpinnings that contribute to aging
and the good news for us is that the
ability to do all these sequencing
technologies gets cheaper each year and
so there's an increasingly number of
studies investigating this
for example this brings me onto a recent
study that has identified some rare
genetic coding variants in a cohort of
515 ashkenazi jewish centenarians
by having a cocoa or similar descendants
it helps to homogenize the genetic
background
making it hopefully easier to detect any
causal variants linked to longevity
anyway what did they see
well they sort of further confirmed what
are seen in model organisms such that
there was a longevity association of
rare variants in the insulin and ampk
signaling pathways although not in the
mtor pathway this time
but interestingly they also found
pathways linked to human aging that have
not yet been identified in modern
organisms such as protective effects or
rare variants in the wind signaling
pathway on human lifespan
interestingly the wind signaling pathway
is often spoken about in terms of stem
cells and so maybe that's why link could
be associated between the wind
signalling and aging but these genetic
studies whilst they're very informative
they don't actually provide any
knowledge about the molecular impact of
these genetic variants for example how
exactly is wind signaling altered in
these centenarians is it enhanced or
repressed
but nonetheless the study confirms the
role that genetics can play in the aging
process
but hang on a minute there is still a
really important point to discuss
just how much of aging can be accounted
for by genetics or in fancier words how
heritable is longevity
well heritability is the ratio of the
genetic component to the sum of the
genetic and environmental factors
now there is no right or wrong answer to
the heritability of human lifespan
simply because heritability seems to be
specific to a population and the
environmental exposure current in that
population
but anyway so far estimates range from
around 20 to 30 from twin studies to 48
and 33 in men and women respectively if
it's a family with a centenarian
but it's also thought that these may be
over estimates with heritability of
longevity being closer to 16
or even below 10
so all in all that is evidently a
genetic component to longevity and
identifying further pathways with
genetics linked to aging and or
age-related diseases offers insight into
novel pathways that could be intervened
pharmacologically which is a good thing
so with that i hope you've enjoyed this
video on the genetics of aging thank you
to my patreon supporters and thank you
for listening